THE GOLDEN KNIGHTS S  NDS A TWO
THE OTHER WAY--
TAKE OVER. .  SHARI.
--  ZUCKER
THEY CONTINUE  STONE
. HOT, PENALTY ON THE
PENGUINS.TH THE WRIST SHOT.
THE TRENCH A GETS INTO THE NET
AND IT'S GOING TO
>> Dave: DURING THE HOMESTAND,
THEY WERE TERRIFICEN HAD TO MIS
DUE TO COVID PROTOCOL.GOLDEN
KNIGHTS A COUPLE OF
NOW JANMARK
SO SOME HUGE SAVES.
WHENEN
>> Shane: HE DID NOT QUIT. GET
A SAVE, LEHNER REBOUND SCORE
AND THE PENGUINSA DOOR AND
THAT IS THE FOLLOW-UP . LEHNER
MAKES
PINCHING IN, HE WILL BANK IT
THE STOP. FOR THE SHOT
HE  AND A GREAT HEADS UP
PLAY AS HE GOES FOR THE
WRAPAROUND.
PIETRANGELO UP HIGH, DOWN LOW P
WHO FINDS JANMARK.
THE TOP DIVISIONS, THE METRO,
THE ATLANTIC.
THE D.
CROSBY SCORES INTO THE EMPTY
NET.T UP  THE ONE
TIMER THAT COMES RIGHT OUT.